[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est Patrick
Pelou bonjour merci d'être avec nous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
président de l'Association des médecins
urgentistes de France ancien chroniqueur
à Charlie heb2 et Patrick Pelou on AAZ
évidemment envie d'avoir votre regard
sur le climat actuel on va commencer par
ce qui s'est passé hier puisque Pier av
hier matin avaiit lieu les obsèques de
Dominique Bernard ce professeur de
français qui a été tué dans une attaque
islamiste à haras c'était vendredi
dernier qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti
quand vous avez appris sa mort ah ça moi
j'ai été bouleversé bouleversé j'ai
pensé à à à sa famille à ses proches
d'ailleurs ce que ses filles et sa femme
ont dit hier pendant les obsècles était
vraiment d'une tristesse et quel c'est
c'est c'est épouvantable voilà c'est
épouvantable et il y a qu'est-ce que
j'ai ressenti une espèce de rage
euh une rage qu'il faut absolument
canaliser
vers le courage de combattre euh
l'islamisme le ce radicalisme ce
fascisme d'accord qui gangrainene le
pays depuis des années en gros même si
euh
quelcal dans les années 90 avait fait
ses attentats c'était les prémises
d'accord bon après 2012 2015 et puis
maintenant c'est les écoles bon donc il
s'attaque à quoi l'islamisme radical et
ces fascistes veulent absolument en fait
aboutir à un islam politique en France
et à imposer la charia bon la charia
dont les premières victimes seront les
femmes et moi j'ai une espèce de volonté
de combattre ça parce que d'abord pour
la République pour la laïcité pour des
buts qui sont vraiment le progrès social
notamment pourquoi le progrès social
parce que vous apercevez qu'ils
attaquent les écoles très bien il tuent
les professeurs voilà mais je je je je
suis on va en parler évidemment de ce
combat mais là vendredi dernier on a
quand même eu un professeur vous le
dites qui s'est fait poignarder devant
son école victime d'une que islamiste
parce qu'il était professeur il y a pas
eu de mobilisation dans les rues il y a
pas de Français qui sont descendus
massivement dans les rues est-ce que
vous avez l'impression queil y a une
forme on s'habitue finalement à
l'horreur ça c'est non mais ce que vous
dites c'est c'est très embêtant
c'est-à-dire que d'un
coup vous avez des émeutes parce que la
police euh il y a eu un drame où un
jeunne a été abattu et il y a des
émeutes partout vousz avvez un
professeur qui est assassiné ça bouge
pas oui on sait qu'en 2015 dans certains
quartiers notamment après le 13 novembre
euh ça ça chantait un peu bon c'est un
problème c'est un problème parce que en
effet c'est sans doute parce qu'on na
pas su même des gens un peu engagés
comme moi on n' pas su descendre en fait
dans les dans les écoles dans les lieux
publics pour porter cette voix et dire
aux gens attention parce que c'est en
fait devant votre porte ça peut vous
arriver d'accord euh là on sait en gros
qu'il va de toute façon se passer
quelque chose sur Paris on le sent on le
sait d'accord et et ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une mobilisation
les gens qui ne bougent pas qui ne vont
pas j'ai j'ai vu comme vous j'avais de
la un peu je m'attendais à ce que devant
l'église à araser ce soit noir de monde
et j'ai culpabilisé parce que bon je
travaillais j'étais devant l'écran je je
regardais en même temps je je régulais
au SAMU de Paris et je disais mais
j'aurais dû être là-bas et en fait la
même mobilisation qu' avait eu le 11
janvier après Charlie Hebdo où il y
avait pas eu que la manifestation avec
des millions de personnes dans les rues
à Paris mais devant toutes les mairies
il faut retrouver ça alors peut-être que
ça veut dire qu'il faut remettre un peu
les choses dans le bon ordre ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est pas
parce que vous condamnez ce fascisme
islamiste ces attentats et que vous
montrer que ce radicalisme religieux qui
veut la mort d'une civilisation en fait
parce que c'est c'est rien d'autre la
charia c'est cet aboutissement
et bon ça veut dire qu'il faut
absolument remobiliser les gens avoir
une réflexion est-ce que ça veut pas
dire d'arrêter pendant une journée en
France en disant attendez là on remet
dans l'ordre écouter la parole des
démocrates des vrais démocrates pas des
extrêmes écouter ce que veut dire la
laïcité regardez ce qu'a été la conquête
de la laïcité dans notre pays et vous
pensez que c'est quoi aujourd'hui chez
les Français c'est de la résignation
c'est de la peur qui conduit à la
lâcheté ou c'est de la naïveté face à ce
qui est en train de se passer il faut
regarder la classe politique vous avez
une classe politique qui est lamentable
d'accord à part quelques personnalités
voà là à droite comme à gauche mais en
gros c'est pas terrible c'est à eux de
de mobiliser c'est à eux de dire mais
c'est vrai que vous avez quandê il
soncore contendabl aujourd'hui les
polities non surtout la gauche la gauche
qui a délaissé la laïcité alors
peut-être que là c'est en train de
rebouger mais si vous voulez quand il y
a eu ces espèce de
tergiversation maladroite malsine mais
oui le Hamas c'est une c'est c'est du
terrorisme oui le Hamas fait du mal y
compris et avant tout aux Palestiniens
d'accord et là vous avez eu des espèces
de de rondeurs machin machin mais ils se
rendent pas compte vous appelez ça des
rondeurs vous le fait de pas qualifier
le Hamas de
terrorisme c'est n'importe quoi ils se
sont trompés d'ailleurs ça a coulé
laanupe là bon et ben des gens de gauche
comme moi on est orphelin quelque chose
or il faudrait il faudrait des si vous
voulez des des joress parce que
l'histoire de la gauche c'est ça c
joress c'est les discours de de miterran
c'est c'est tout ça de la grandeur de
l'humanisme la laïcité et de combattre
ce qui se passe parce que quand vous
regardez et c'est vrai vous avez raison
cette espèce de de fait que les Français
et français ne bougent pas plus que ça
on vient de d'assassiner encore un
professeur en attaquant une école c'est
très grave alors heureusement il y a de
l'espoir vous avez Gabriel atthal pour
il représente l'espoir Gabriel atthal
mais écoutez enfin on a un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui dit écoutez la
BAA ça suffit là et qui dit à
l'Assemblée c'est c'est c'est terminé on
arrête parce que si vous voulez de dire
ah les les les les pauvres ils sont
radicalisés ah qu'est-ce qu'on ah il
faut de la compassion ah c'est des
raisons sociales ça à un moment donné ça
ça suffit ça suffit ça suffit mais
est-ce que justement alors là vous dites
Gabriel Atal c'est l'espoir j'en déduis
que vous constatez un changement de
ligne politique par rapport à avant
est-ce qu'il y a eu trop de
tergiversation trop d'osiliation
politique sur cette question de la lutte
mais oui mais vous savez c'est ce que
moi j'ai vécu après mais comme les
autres comme tout le monde après les
attentats de Charli do vous aviez ah
l'attentat oui
mais oui mais ça annule tout d'accord le
problème est pas là ce qu'on réussit les
Frères musulmans ceux qui réussissent
par le djihad c'est de dire si vous les
condamnez vous êtes raciste vous dites
le mot musulman vous êtes raciste vous
êtes le mot Islam vous êtes raciste pas
du tout pas du tout écoutez lisez ce que
disent certains journalistes comme
Soline chalvon quand elle vous décrit la
société moyenageuse que les talibans
sont en train de refaire en Afghanistan
regardez ce qui se passe au Pakistan
regardez partout où de toute façon
al-qïda daesh l'État islamique tout ça
tout tout ça tout ça ça monte doucement
en puissance faut les combattre c'est
une vraie guerre voilà et c'est vrai je
pense que c'est
transcourant sur l'idée de ce qu'est la
République moi je n'ai en fait j'ai
envie de vous dire mon parti c'est la
République voilà et pour vous
aujourd'hui on est en guerre pour vous
aujourd'hui on est en guerre c'est mais
oui c'est une vraie guerre regardez ce
qu'ils font le le le le le le
l'islamiste qui a tué les deux suédois
qui sont des supporteur de foot parce
qu'ils viennent supporter leur équipe et
le type après il air dans Bruxelles il
tire de partout comment on en est
arrivriver là comment on a laissé
molenbeck devenir enfin perdu c'est
c'est c'est et c'est l'Europe c'est
l'Europe mais justement est-ce qu'on est
prêt à la mener cette guerre est-ce que
les gens ont conscience qu'on est en
guerre vous vous dites on est en guerre
est-ce que c'est partagconscience
l'inconscience a été de croire que nous
avions la paix pour l'éternité
l'inconscience est de croire que les
choses sont acquises peuple de gauche la
laïcité n'est pas acquise ça reste un
combat permanent ça reste une
mobilisation quand vous voyez les
sondages chez les jeunes les plus jeunes
qui croient plus dans la parole du Coran
que dans les lois de la République il y
a du boulot là il y a du boulotut faut
expliquer pourquoi d'accord parce que
dans quelques temps ils vont nous
réexpliquer que finalement c'est normal
de faire travailler les enfants que les
femmes il faut c'est normal qu'elles
porte le voile et cetera et cetera il y
a aussi un échec de l'école là-dessus
écoutez non c'est pas un échec de
l'école l'école elle peut pas tout faire
elle peut pas avoir et calmer les
carences que la politique fait c'est
exactement comme les urgences de
l'hôpital l'école d'accord nous on est
devenu la dernière roue du Carros de
toutes les dysfonctionnements sanitaires
sociaux et cetera et cetera tout ça ça
arrive aux urgences l'école c'est pareil
chaque fois qu'il y a un problème dans
la société l'école non l'école il faut
qu'elle structure l'intelligence la
liberté de choix de penser et la culture
de la République ce qu'elle fait avec
évidemment amasser les connaissances
formé des cerveaux pour pas que ça soit
des cerveaux qui n'utilisent qu'un doigt
pour regarder les réseaux sociaux à
l'avenir non pour que vous ayez des gens
qui soient intellectuellement développé
c'est un combat ce combat l'islam
radical et fasciste ne veut pas le mener
c'est pour ça qu'ils attaquent les
écoles et les enseignants c'est ça le
truc mais ce combat dans la lutte contre
l'islamisme qui va au-delà de l'école
évidemment est-ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui qu'il est perdu
non jamais jamais
jamais nous sommes on est la France nous
sommes l'Europe on a connu des
oppressions on a connu l'oppression du
nazisme l'oppression des religions on a
toujours gagné et là simplement en effet
c'est là où je vous dis que des
personnalités comme Gabriel Atal Castex
Hollande avait raison la déchéance de
nationalité qu'on n pas voulu faire mais
c'est Hollande qui a raison là qu'est-ce
qui s'est dit ces derniers jours bah il
faut leur enlever la nationalé mais
évidemment si vous n'avez pas de
correction et de choses on sait parce
que zinabel razoui mon ami qui qui qui
avait traduit avant les attentats de
Charlie dans les années 2010-21 des
textes faits par les Frères musulmans en
Égypte qui disaient c'est super facile
en fait de conquérir la France et et
l'Allemagne parce qu'ils sont pas
mobilisés et en gros on était devenus
des caves bah en fait ils avaent raison
parce que d'un coup ils ont les éléments
de langage pour nous la jouer à l'envers
c'est c'est c'est le fameux truc ils
connaissent nos faiblesses mais nos
faiblesses sont aussi notre force
sociale et c'est ça qui va pas ils
utilisent ce qui a été l'embellissement
social et le fait qu'on donne pour dire
voilà on vous détourne le truc c'est
c'est ça le truc et quand d'un coup les
les les les personnes de gauche
défendent le fait de laaba à l'école
mais il se gourent complètement disent
le voile c'est une liberté et cetera
mais mais bon sang mais ils ont vu ce
qui se passait en Iran où les femmes se
battent pour plus avoir le voile et ils
ont compris et nous on serait dans la
régression en disant non mais la
religion finalement parce que vous dites
que ça pourrait arriver chez nous ce qui
se passe en Afghanistan ce qui se passe
en mais bien sûr mais bien sûr mais bien
sûr bien sûr là ce qui se passe c'est
qu'en fait derrière le Hamas se cache
les réseaux d'intégrisme et de fascisme
tel alqadi Ida daesh l'Iran qui veulent
la la conquête du monde ouvrez les yeux
c'est c'est c'est ça leur truc c'est ça
leur truc bien malgré nous mais quand
ils manipulent quand ils ont manipulé
parce que c'est ça la vérité de
l'histoire quand ils ont manipulé en en
2005 2006 les caricatures danoises et
qu' on avait reproduit à Charli c'était
une manipulation politique et après sur
des pays ils ont truqué les dessins pour
galvaniser des foules qui sont par
l'absence de politique éducative et
d'émancipation de l'intelligence dans
leur pays d'accord il est ils ont
galvanisé pour en fait construire une
haine contre l'Occident et et c'est ça
qui qui qui ne va pas et et d'un coup de
dire ah non mais les pauvres il faut
mettre plus de mosquée plus de religion
plus d'églises et cetera mais écoutez
non c'est c'est la religion nous sommes
un pays laïque c'est pour ça quand ils
veulent réformer la Constitution moi je
pense que je seraai assez d'accord de
remettre liberté égalité fraternité
laïcité je pense que si vous voulez faut
compléter les trois mots qui avaient été
fait par Robespierre d'accord pour
ajouter la laïcité il faut la réaffirmer
je sais qu'on est un satellite à travers
le monde d'accord parce que évidemment
la première soi-disant puissance
mondiale des États-Unis il mettent Dieu
partout sur les billets de banque et
cetera voilà on est un satellite sur la
laïcité ils comprennent pas d'ailleurs
les Nations Unies disent ah mais avec
votre laïcité ils ont réussi à
inverser la laïcité en disant la laïcité
est une oppression mais non c'est
émancipation mais voilà on na pas été
assez fort assez pugnass et on c'est
beaucoup la gauche pour vous ou c'est
généralisé non non c'est général c'est
général parce que si vous voulez euh à à
à part que voilà d'un coup on reste sur
la République on ne fait pas de
concession quand il demande de
construire
X X mosquée dans des dans des régions où
finalement vous apercevez par les études
qui sont faites qu' y a pas plus de de
monter que ça il y a ça bouge pas sur le
monde de de de croyants mais vous avez
une conquête et on sait très bien que le
Qatar l'Arabie Saoudite arrive et fil du
pognon pour construire un maximum de de
de lieux de culte et et cultuel bon
voilà après vous avez une mobilisation
des préfets qui est quand même réelle
sur des écoles coraniques qui essayent
de se monter même dans les caves et
cetera c'est c'est vraiment une
mobilisation générale si vous l'avez pas
oui et et là de toute façon et je joue
pas les cassandres ou les oiseaux de
mauvais augur faut juste savoir qu'on
est extrêmement mobilisé à Paris tant au
niveau du Samu de Paris que des pompiers
de Paris que de la préfecture et cetera
et cetera tout le monde en se disant oui
ils vont réattaquer de toute façon à un
moment ou un autre c'est vous attendez
un attentat des attaque imminante oui
oui parce que d'abord ils l'ont dit dans
leur journal d'alqaïda là leur leur
feuilles la machin et faut les prendre
très au sérieux c'est pour ça si vous
voulez se défendre c'est aussi une
réponse à l'attaque je veux dire voyez
on se on a une police qui est très
efficace on a une police qui est qui est
très forte qui qui sait faire et cetera
bon voilà ils ont mais mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'en 2015 on a
connu des attaques qui étaient très
coordonnés des attaques d'envd
aujourd'hui on le voit on a l'impression
que ce sont des assaillants qui sont
isolés qui sont très difficilement
détectable puisqu'on l'a vu la saandara
s'était suivi et Elisabeth borne l'a dit
il y avait pas de signe avant couroureur
de passage à l' il y en a pas c'est plus
compliqué aujourd'i c'est ils sont très
forts ils sont très forts vous avez vu
le type qui a attaqué il a vu les
policiers la veille non moi je continue
je fais des maquettes de bateau tout va
bien vous inquiétez pas machin il y a
pas de signe il y a pas de signe et le
type je suis convaincu qu'il avait déjà
prévu le truc c'est très compliqué nous
avons un monde qui est très complexe
mais on a une police qui est efficace
mais il faut lui donner encore plus de
moyens notamment sur le renseignement et
et pister tout ce petit monde et
probablement ne pas utiliser que le
tazer quand on essaie de les neutraliser
parce que là en fait qu'est-ce qui va
devenir il va aller en prison et en
prison bah il se passe rien parce qu'on
on ne sait pas déradiquer c'est faux on
ne sait pas déradicaliser quelqu'un il
va aller en prison et ca qu'est- qu'on
fait alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait il faut
se défendre il faut il faut c'est c'est
c'est c'est extrêmement complexe il faut
être beaucoup plus pugnass c'est pour ça
quand d'un coup le le le gouvernement
dit attendez les fichiers s maintenant
ça tourne dans leur pays oui c'est ça
faut remettre un outil légal beaucoup
plus fort et et qu'on soit beaucoup plus
donc il faut des lois plus dures
puisqu'on va être en plein débat sur la
loi notamment immigrationén il faut des
lois plus dur cher amis on je si j'ai
bien compris ce que disent les juges et
on croule déjà sous les lois faut déjà
appliquer les lois existan c'estàdire
que quand d'un coup vous avez des
personnes qui doivent être reconduites à
la frontière elles sont pas reconduites
en fonction du temps elles sont
reconduites tout de suite voilà c'est
simple après qu' a des recours quand il
pour il faut faciliter accélérer des
distions mais évidemment et puis d'autre
part mais vous savez que c'est pas
toujours facile Patrick Pelot avec des
pays qui n'en veulent pas comment on
fait ah bah le le le truc écoutez quand
il y a un problème avec un Français à
travers le monde on le rapatrie
facilement donc voilà faut que ça soit
pareil avec eux après il c'est c'est
c'est à ces payslà de de de les assumer
si vous ne faites pas ça et ben on en
fait ils nous prennent pour des
endouilles et il ils vont ils vont
continuer et et vous pouvez pas et quand
vous regardez la courbe des attentats
islamistes et de ce qui se passe alors
en effet ils change parce que en fait
ils sont très surveillés sur les armes
mais on sait ça c'est les les
conclusions qui avait eu surtout les les
enseignements que je je que je tire des
procès Charlie Hebdo 13 novembre et
cetera c'est de toute façon en plus vous
avez une collusion entre le trafic de
drogue le trafic d'armes le terrorisme
donc il y a aussi des trucs à la racine
qui qui qui qu'il faut avoir
faut pas être dans un une situation
confortable nous sommes trop dans une
situation confortable on doit être dans
une situation d'attaque contre le
fanatisme religieux islamiste si on fait
pas ça on n arrivera pas l'assayant
d'aras il est arrivé en France à l'âge
de 6 ans il a été éduqué à l'école
française par la République française
par la République française il a fini
par par tuer un professeur est-ce que ça
remet aussi en cause notre modèle
d'intégration non parce que on va pas
généraliser un modèle d'intégration pour
un un c'est pas possible faut
faut pas se laisser ébranler mais ça
veut dire que quand d'un coup vous avez
parce que c'est ça le truc un fichier s
qu'est-ce qui se passe et cetera il ils
devaient tous reconduit à la frontière
et puis il y a eu des recours et cetera
et puis un espèce de jeu juridique qui
est
trop qui qui qui facilite trop leur
tâche voyez et et et d'un
coup on doit estêtre beaucoup plus
pugnasse que ça et beaucoup plus
efficace sur l'application des lois
parce que derrière ça alors sans doute
que la réponse parce que c'est vrai que
si vous voulez l'Europe est pas facile à
à à à contrôler vraiment que que les
gouvernement se mettent autour de la
table pour savoir comment on sécurise
beaucoup plus l'Europe c'est alors après
il y a sans doute des choses qu'on ne
sait pas et qu'il faut garder secret sur
l'action qui est faite par les services
secrets et j'espère qu' y en a
d'ailleurs mais il faut il faut il faut
être beaucoup plus plusnasse que ça sur
ceux qui viennent juste
pour réussir à monter un djihad en
France c'est pas possible un dernier mot
puisque vous avez été plutôt assez
critique durant cette interview sur la
gauche comment vous la qualifiez la
gauche aujourd'hui euh dépressive hein
elle va pas bien elle va pas bien mais
on a besoin de la gauche he moi je reste
profondément de gauche mais j'attends
vraiment des discours sur le sens des
services publics la laïcité et voilà des
des des des choses des choses comme ça
sur des pr aujourd'hui la voix qu'on
entend beaucoup à gauche c'est celle de
Jean-Luc Mélanchon oui mais alors ça
sert aussi si vous voulez cette chasse
au à à une personne euh elle elle est
très
malsine tout ça ça fait le lit de
l'arrivée de l'extrême droite au pouvoir
et la France je je vous je vous dis ne
devrait pas penser que l'extrême droite
au pouvoir pourra résoudre les problèmes
non non c'est c'est ça ne fonctionnera
pas on on le voit dans tous les pays où
l'extrême droite est arrivé au pouvoir
ça ne fonctionnera pas non mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit faire cette
gauche que doiv faire les socialistes
les communistes les verts ils doivent
rompre avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils
doivent pas rompre ça je sais pas
écoutez ça ça ça c'est des jeux de
personne moi je pense qu'avant toute
chose c'est les c'est aussi des jeux de
ligne c'est regarder l'histoire c'est
regarder prendre juste un petit peu de
temps faut pas qu'on ait la mémoire des
poissons rouges avec les réseaux sociaux
de type Twitter machin qui qui est
vraiment un truc à à massacrer les les
les peuples à mon sens le le le truc
c'est de se replonger sur l'histoire ce
qui a fait l'histoire de la gauche
d'accord ce qui a fait la Commune de
Paris je reste ce qui a fait la force de
la France c'est quand d'un coup le
gaulisme s'est épaulé sur justement le
communisme et ils ont inventé la
sécurité sociale c'est toutes ces
valeurslà c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
retrouver un sens profond de la gauche
et surtout que la gauche réoccupe le
terrain de la laïcité parce que
actuellement le parti qui défend et
souvent ce que dit Marine Le Pen est
juste sur la laïcité mais ce discours là
pourquoi la gauche l'a oublié et
pourquoi ce
nouveau parce que par clientélisme je je
je je je crois en croyant et en
utilisant en fait le vocabulaire qu'ont
eu les salafistes les Frères musulmans
en disant la la est une oppression mais
c'est c'est un mensonge de dire ça c'est
comme d'avoir inventé le concept
d'islamophobie là c'est sûr tout le
monde va dire je suis islamophobe mais
pas du tout les premières victimes de
l'islam et du fascisme islamistes ce
sont les musulmans et notamment les
femmes musulmanes merci Patrick Pelou
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin et d'avoir accepté cet
entretien on on passe tout de suite au
club des territoires